we're back Mme no hi my name is grace
helbig you do not know now you know
you're like different now I'm here with
the one and only memory heart and some
silent discouraging but ultimately
exciting news yes it's a little sad
which is why I dressed as a clown today
whoa everybody if you haven't heard this
my kid has come to an end unfortunately
it's a decision that was out of our
hands we did not want it to end as
abruptly as it did nor did we wanted to
end or not people might be like oh they
just got lazy or like it was too much
work no no no no no there's a whole
business side of things that we can't
control
it's a fact oh we're still making
content on our own respective YouTube
channel and this might get burning we
have a new Phoenix that's rising from
the ashes oh yeah this might get weird
it's the new podcast that meri and I
will be doing this make it weird once a
week every Wednesday because we just
like hanging out with each other
ha no we thought one of the coolest most
fun ways to still make content for you
guys regularly it would be a podcast
with less showering less showering more
law more candid unfiltered conversation
because we were a little beholding to
you know standard some practices on this
might get now you get us completely
curse words all up in da home all of
them we're gonna upload every Wednesday
my podcast not your deed comes out of
Mondays and then like Tyler and Hannah
how they think their podcasts on
Tuesdays and then this might get weird
will be Wednesday's nice little hump day
to keep you going
they'll be links in the description
hopefully if we have figured out how to
load it to the banking devices so check
out
down there he thought that we made a
couple videos who made one on memories
channel about you know having to console
our parents at the end of this might get
and then looking at text conversations
that go weird with your parents yes I
thought we'd do something kind of
similar here because it wasn't our
choice for the show to end it feels a
little bit like we're being broken up
with oh yeah yeah yeah feel so good I
thought I'd reach out to you guys and
ask for some of your worst breakup
stories so we can all come to Zuri
together and maybe find the humor in it
rather than the sadness I'm gonna be
knee-deep in a pint of Ben and Jerry's
right onto this but yeah Tyler Oakley
just respond I'm sorry I can't don't
hate me oh my gosh that's the sticky
note from Sex in the City at the burger
episode is it yeah so we're just
starting off on a fictitious I like you
sent me this we all I think that
snapchat right yeah this is real this is
a she person and also what a hilariously
like petty way to do this yeah like you
can't even save it and we also what a
terrible angle so like you yeah like I
can't even imagine the dick effects your
son oh it was friend to jump me through
a video game I logged off right after
without replying so he asked me the next
day if I saw it I was 11 but still back
when I was a kid you'd have to like do
it yourself in person or on the phone or
however have a friend do it I've broken
up with by someone's friend and I was in
my last class of the day in seventh
grade like a history class and before
the bell rang she likes
told me he didn't want to date anymore I
think she was him in the class and just
left and then I was like oh my god
birthday party at 5th grade and the two
hotties they approached me at the same
time and we're like we want you to date
both of us and I was like cool yeah no
problem
you guys are opposite of know if you
guys are down with that I'm down with
that and then I suppose that by the end
of the birthday party I got dumped by
both of them
so you were in the throttle for a very
brief moment of time and then they both
individually dumped me you know what you
posted a son he's like a Doublemint
commercial oh yeah I broke up with me
over the phone while I was at a hospital
waiting for my mom to wake up from
cancer surgery I thought he called to
comfort me he forgot where I was that
day he tried to backpedal no way dude
you started it best finish it you're
that guy now huh another guy dumped me
at Disneyland
Jesus Christina where's the attraction
problem to the these does I would like
to have heard him backpedaling birthday
surprise party before the big surprise I
picked up my boyfriend of two years and
he broke up with me an hour into the
party after unsuccessfully trying to
hide the break-up from the 40 friends
and family at the party he asked if I
could drive him home see whoa I don't
know Aaron if it's worse for you or
worse for him you he put himself in that
situation
uh-huh what a dick cherry on top of the
dick Sunday to ask her to drive home how
do you know my favorite food we go in a
mid to late 20s and a guy broke up with
me by sending me a text message via his
work email he definitely works for the
government and then when I didn't freak
out and call him a bunch of names he
called me to tell me that was a test and
because I didn't freak out that meant we
could still be friends
back to who is he
he's probably been fired also a test
like like this is a test of the
government's tech system no I think it's
like that's a test to see if we could
still be friends when it's like you
don't get a consolation prize
no I get to dump me and you decide if we
should still be friend of course not
Mallory says when I was in middle school
this guy asked me out and I said yes I
think we did it for a week before he had
his friend send me a message on AIM that
said my boyfriend want to break up with
me he also sent me a link to I don't
love you but my My Chemical Romance
music video wow yeah
really turn the night off of just such a
dork going through something if he was
jamming to My Chemical Romance all the
time I buy my first boyfriend of a year
and a half during a game of Sling no
pirates revenge
an online bingo game that we played
there was a chat box and we've been
talking normally and all of a sudden I
got we should see other people
Wow in the middle of your games Lego
Pirates revenge did you guys meet in
person or were you dating like a 95 year
old okay week I mean he got the flu and
then never answered me again and then
his mom told my best friend about his
new girlfriend is her name flu oh yeah
it could be like an old name like
Gertrude or flu in cartoon exactly right
to my car I said I appreciate you doing
this for me he said I appreciate your
friendship but also you got your brakes
fix out yeah but it breaks on the
relations on has a rap song at well
Rocketman is sampled like a rice
andouille yeah there's no proof I mean
how to tattoo anyway sidebar sighs nice
British guy on tinder he was very sweet
bought me two flavors of chips
says he'll be my stability when I tell
him my life is a little crazy right now
three days later his phone is
disconnected he moved back to England
again you got free chips though you got
chips like wearing these guys that are
fixing your brain
and buying new chips and then piece it
out like that's the relationship I want
post mix oh oh god here's an actual
screen grab of break out knock knock
who's there
single single who single you what you
singled out I don't know this is real if
this is real
Wow what a complicated way to get there
he's still not wrong this one is really
long but this is the last one
okay I've kind of scanned this earlier
but I've got a deep dive into it it's a
couple different things right okay so I
did a boy for six months and was totally
in love with him I picked him up one day
and he was like don't be mad but last
night I did cocaine and that was the
beginning of the end and then he texted
me at 2:30 a.m. when he knew I had to
work in nine am and send me this I mean
there's a lot going on we need to talk
about it in person I don't think so it
could be a phone call where we could
just both agree that our relationship
isn't good for either of us and end it
right now we're you're amazing
well you're gonna have an amazing life
I'm sorry I wasted your time we often
say this to my face
talk to me tomorrow not right now this
is the last text you'll get from me I
wish you the absolute best you're the
amazing person I'm not going to contact
you further because I know it's just
going to hurt you I enjoy your company
into honestly sorry it didn't work out
it's really not you it's me
I hate to be cliche but it's the truth
take care and then they said so this is
in April this year but guess who won
[ __ ] because last night I got this text
are you up not even apply message
rolling back looks like someone on your
nails doing that cocaine is a one-time
thing you know like good for you to the
upper hand
upper end and also the whole like say to
my face like you came up came out
swinging yeah that you're like don't be
a [ __ ] you were the responsible mature
one also please leave in the comments
and you responded or if you've heard
more from him yeah well I'm curious
we're invested in this saga now and I
guess our version of that is now our
friend is there
yeah yeah guys go subscribe to the
podcast now so you don't miss it when
it's uploaded cuz we're gonna be
figuring this out as we go yeah like
leave comments if you have ideas for it
we're gonna kind of like figure it out
as we go and see what we want to talk
about and how would I talk about things
but let us know in the comments down
below like what you think we should be
talking about what you'd like to hear it
from us build this together yeah don't
drop us
don't jump bus please also make sure you
go check out memories video on her
channel because parents and phones they
just don't understand well Smith's been
saying it for 30 years so I don't know
what is it misery loves company and then
maybe it becomes the opposite of misery
strength in numbers
okay sure